foreign
first of all welcome it's really great
to have all you here it's it feels so
good to be doing reunions again in
person and getting to several people on
campus and it's really wonderful to have
you all you all back here to see each
other and celebrate your reunions I
think what I'd like to do with this
session is is actually most spend most
of the time just hearing your questions
and having a discussion but I'll spend a
few minutes at the beginning just kind
of giving you a little bit of an update
on the on the school and telling you how
things are things are going
um I I thought I just might start by
saying um so yesterday we had a the
first faculty Senate meeting of the year
at Stanford and my colleague the dean of
the medical school uh spoke and he said
something that just really resonated
with me
um which was he he was he was talking
about the pretty challenging last 32
months that we've had at Stanford
including
four entire quarters that were pretty
much on Zoom when we had no
undergraduates on the campus the MBA
students and the MSX students were here
on campus but classes were largely on
Zoom and uh and the faculty were
teaching from home on uh on their
computers
and he said that his dominant feeling
looking back over the last uh 32 months
was uh was gratitude
there was gratitude for the incredible
effort and adaptability and resilience
that faculty showed in having to rethink
teaching after doing it the same way for
years and sometimes decades
that the that students showed in having
good will to get through the the
pandemic that our staff showed and
having to navigate things uh and the and
the Goodwill that alumni showed in
helping to support the school through a
pretty tough and the university threw a
pretty tough uh time
and and so I that that I I really that
really resonated with me and even more
than gratitude for the last the period
going through covet I have felt
tremendous gratitude being back on
campus I I came to Stanford for the
first time as an undergraduate
I was 17 years old
and I've been here spent most of my life
since then here on campus 22 years on
the faculty six years here at the gsbsdn
and basically have loved every minute of
being on this campus for all that time
but have never felt more appreciation
for the campus than I have
this year and last year when we brought
people back
and
there's lots of reasons for that
actually but part of it is you know the
GSB is in particular University as a
whole but the GSP particular it's a it
is a unique place there is really
nowhere else like it I think anywhere
else in the world
you know it is a place where on the one
hand we have these unbelievable
brilliant you know Scholars and faculty
who are Milling around and some of you I
know this morning came and saw hito and
Ben's our faculty member speak if he won
the Nobel prize in economics last year
his colleague Bob Wilson won it the year
before
you know this week Carolyn bertozi our
colleague in chemistry won the Nobel
Prize like that's who you get to be on
the faculty with at Stanford and learn
from in classrooms it's amazing and the
GSB is we have a more than our fair
share of those people here even relative
to the chemistry department and the
engineering school
and then you know you pair that with
the incredible leadership potential and
action orientation and ambition of the
students who come into the school every
year
and you know that mix of great ideas and
great leadership potential ambition
drive to action there's just
there's just about nowhere on the planet
that puts those things together in one
place
but of course what makes it not just
kind of a bunch of independent people
doing interesting things is all being
together and the bumping into each other
and the interacting and whether it's
students connecting or people in
classrooms or just
you all being here running into students
to faculty the mixing it up
that happens on the campus that's that's
where the Alchemy is the magic of this
place the magic of Stanford and missing
that for 18 months just really brought
back how special that is and how
fortunate we are to get to be here in
that environment and and how much
potential there is just at any of the
potential energy of having those
interactions is just incredible
so that's that's it's been a really it's
really great to have you back and this
is the first real reunion back in you
know kind of full-on uh post covered
that we've had and so it feels so good
to see all of you here and and get to to
uh interact with you and give you a
chance to be together and I hope you get
a sense of just how vibrant the campus
feels right now it feels incredible to
walk in walk in every day
let me say one more more thing and then
and then I'll just open up for
discussion which is I if I had to pick
one other uh Lloyd started yesterday in
the Lloyd minor uh from the school said
his one word for the uh
uh for his feeling right now was was
gratitude and and I said that resonated
if I had to pick one word
it would be opportunity
that um
you know
we have been through just in the last
few years such a period of extraordinary
change in the world
and change in business change in society
politics
and you know a time when there's first
of all been incredible changes in
technology I mean we're going to go
through a rethinking of work this year
for the first time in a hundred years
probably of how people interact and and
work
societal changes more awareness about
issues like inequality the role of
business and fostering opportunity
climate change this year at Stanford we
have a new school for the first time in
75 years the school of sustainability
and we're doing all kinds of stuff this
year with uh with the sustainability
school around business sustainability I
know some of you came to the session
earlier earlier today
and when you have a period of just
incredible change and disruption in the
world and when people are sort of
thinking in particular about the role of
business and addressing those changes
addressing some of the challenges we
have
that's a great time to be at the
business school like that's just a great
time to be on campus Because you've got
people are thinking they want to debate
they want to talk about it they want to
come up with Solutions
and that just is such a great feeling of
opportunity right now and you're going
to get to hear a few minutes from
Annette at mighty one of our faculty who
has been really at the Forefront of this
and set up a
initiative at school the corporations
Society initiative about five years she
really anticipated actually a lot of the
changes that are happening thinking
about the purpose of Corporations and
the role of business so she'll talk
about some of the things that she's been
doing and that's been a big area of
activity for us at the school so as we
think about the curriculum and faculty
research and and uh and are engaged with
the university and with the world
so let me stop there
and uh and I'll just open up and I'd
love to you know I'm happy to hear any
questions you have about just about
anything so I might as well I think I'll
just leave it to you to sort of Drive
the direction we go in and and uh
okay
uh
thank you John for amazing work that's
being done at the school and um I wanted
to ask you especially with the opening
of the new school of sustainability this
past week
um what the vision is for the GSB and
interaction with the new school and
addressing
urgent issues in the climate crisis and
specifically if you could comment on the
student protest about uh the university
call for University divestment from
fossil fuels yeah okay thanks Gordon um
so I that's a great question and Broad
so let me let me actually take the first
part and then I can come talk and I can
talk about the the specific issue or
investment
um so actually let me let before I check
with the our relationship with the
school standard let me just actually
step back and see this year one of the
our major initiatives that we're going
to launch this year and probably my top
priority for this year is to launch an
initial we've been calling the business
government and Society initiative and
it's organized around a set of pillars
topics where we think the business
school could have a big impact on issues
that are at the intersection of business
and and Society one of those is
sustainability business sustainability
one is around the effects of Technology
governing and guiding technological
change in ways that will be broadly
beneficial for Humanity one of them is
around the future of markets and
institutions you'll hear more about that
from not when she talks governance
issues purpose of the corporation
institutions that underlie business
the sustainability piece of that
Stanford made a decision two years ago
that we were going to make a major
investment campus-wide in climate and
sustainability uh and that was decision
made by our by our president martesi
Levine and the Provost and
um and there was a committee that looked
at different ways we could do that and
they actually came back with two models
an interesting University governance
story they came up with two models for
how could the university make a huge
push in sustainability be the leading
University
one model was what they were calling a
college so that is every school would
make a would make kind of a push and
then you would network them across the
campus and the other was to create a
school
and we decided to create a school
which I was a Advent School advocate and
the reason I thought the school would be
great is the school is an ecosystem a
school has faculty have to pick who what
research you're going to do what you're
going to teach and so forth and so two
years ago we made that decision the
president made the decision we're going
to have a school first school at
Stanford in 75 years
and you know now it's launched and with
Incredible philanthropy from John door
in a big way
as soon as that decision was made there
was a question of how will the other
schools be involved it's how you need to
have business involved if you're going
to think about climate change energy
transition Innovation that's going to
scale Solutions Technical Solutions that
might come out of great engineering and
Science and so we got started at the
business school having discussions
initially Among The Faculty but then
including lots more people how we're
going to do that and we came up with a
plan for an initiative that bill Barnett
one of our faculty members has been
leading and now it's a joint initiative
with the door school and so when the
door school opened uh in September we
had six faculty who took joint
appointments over in the door school we
have 70 MBA students who are doing a
joint degree with the door School
we have a whole set of classes that are
getting introduced this year we're
running 17 this is actually crazy I
don't know why we're doing this at this
scale but we're running 17 conferences
in business and sustainability one every
two weeks all through the year so
climate Finance accounting Net Zero
operations it's it's a little
overwhelming actually I think anat is
running one on PG e and wildfires that
that I'm gonna I've got to figure out
what I'm gonna say at uh and uh but I
will figure it out or not don't worry uh
we're and then we're going to announce
in a couple of weeks a new
sustainability entrepreneurship program
that we've put together with uh with the
with the door school so
I just think I'm really excited and the
kind of vision that that that that we've
had about the partnership is that this
is an opportunity as we have with other
Stanford schools to marry the incredible
disciplinary expertise in energy and
Innovation and technology in in the rest
of campus with the leadership
entrepreneurship management of the
business school and that's just a
dynamite combination you know that's the
combination that students need to be
successful and you know so that's to
solve problems
you asked about the the divestment from
uh the sort of issues around
um there was a question about the about
whether so there's been a there's been a
lot of debate at Stanford about um
forming this school about whether
Stanford should take money from uh from
fossil fuel companies and there's this
uh there's a there's a I would say
opinions are divided at the University
there's a very vocal group of students
and and some alumni and faculty who feel
very strongly that there we shouldn't
take money from energy companies and
then there's other people who have a
different view that the university
should engage broadly
and and we have the principle of
academic freedom which
says faculty pretty much have the right
to work on whatever they want and uh
that discussion is going to play out
this year basically the dean of the new
school has issued a statement last year
with some principals and is doing a
listening tour and
um they'll they'll have to sort that out
at the at the new school uh over the
over the course of the year how they how
they want to do that
yeah
John there was an article in the Wall
Street Journal in the last week or so
about decline in applications major
Business Schools Stanford was not
mentioned in the article what what's the
experience here and does that suggest a
change in the profile of people who are
applying yeah so the the so the thing to
understand about business school
applications which I think all of you
know some of us we're very very tied to
the labor market
when the labor market is hot
business school applications are down
and when the labor market cools off
business qualifications are up we're
counter cyclical
and and there's for obvious reasons and
last year uh the land market was smoking
hot and our applications were down and I
think they were down by
16 or so
um and this year the landmark could I
guess it's really hard to tell depending
on the numbers you look at how you look
at them there might be very tight or it
might be cooling off so I guess we're
going to find out in the next couple of
weeks what's what's going on
in terms of our class composition the
truth is it hasn't really mattered our
applications I think they are they you
know we're down off our Peak which was
maybe
five years ago or something we had our
Peak year four years ago and then we
were down a little bit covet was very
weird uh with applications we were down
a little bit
other schools were hugely volatile
we get
we
we have two things going for us one is
we take a very small number of students
almost everybody we admit these days
comes
about 90 percent of the students we
admit come
and that's yield is really high and so
we have you know we're very fortunate in
that sense and we've got
we could use we have a class of 2000
that was fantastic and then we have a
class of 420.
so we're in a we're in a pretty good
position
other schools are much more vulnerable
to fluctuations in the in the market
than we are but I'll say one more thing
about that I to where it shows up for us
that so there has been a lot of
discussion about whether there's a sort
of secular decline in them in sort of
two-year residential MBA programs and
there has been actually if you look at
numbers now part of that
is is is
that that statistic is about overall MBA
programs and it would be a little bit
like if you asked you know Stanford's
dean of admissions for undergraduate and
said you know college enrollment is
declining in the U.S are you worried
that Stanford won't have any students in
the undergraduate class and he'd be like
well no we had 60 000 Apple I don't know
how many he had but he'd sort of you
know it would be it would be it sort of
conflating things that are a little bit
different that's a little bit true for
us too
but it but it is a reflection of
something that is affecting us which is
career paths have changed
and so in in fields like Finance in
Consulting in tech companies
you can go far in your career without
ever stopping to get an MBA
so you know in MBA for many years for
some people perceived it as it was a a
necessary rung on the ladder
and I don't think anyone thinks of it
that way now the good thing is we never
thought about it that way and I hope
none of you ever thought about it that
way you know we've always thought of the
NBA at Stanford as not what had you got
up one rung on the ladder it's about how
do you see every possible path you could
take and get the skills to do any of
those things
so that change in overall MBA the sort
of secular changes in MBA programs in
some ways have played to our advantage
because
no student comes in thinking I need to
get this degree to get to my next job
they can get to the next job just fine
they come in thinking how is this going
to set me up for a whole career of
different opportunities and in some ways
that's good that plays to what we were
doing anyway in our program
um but we still keep a close eye on the
your admissions numbers
thank you for the opportunity
um You referred to quite a few changes
in motion globally can you maybe uh kind
of unpack a little bit what are the top
changes among them that really make you
think about what's the strategy or how
do you deliver the ambition of the
school yeah
so well miss mentioned a few I mean I
think one we already talked about the
about climate and sustainability and
that's that's a big priority for us and
certainly with this incredible
opportunity with the university having a
new school to to to really be at the
Forefront of thinking about
um the response to climate change and
um energy transition and that's a I
think that's a great opportunity for us
whether it's entrepreneurship or
thinking about
uh Finance operations different aspects
of management
um
the school is Stanford is deeply wedded
to Silicon Valley and so changes in
technology particularly on digital
Technologies
they come from here like we are the
source of so much of that Innovation and
change
and to my mind one of the big things
that has happened here
um I mean one is just there's been such
a revolution in areas like machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
data and algorithms and that's a great
opportunity for our students because the
you know the combination of the
technological change and the business
model changes that just
that intersection is such a powerful
place to be and it's a place where our
students have the opportunity to get to
um but it's also an area where you know
when I came to Stanford as a faculty
member 20 years ago and I worked on the
economics technology you know it felt in
Silicon Valley like we were really
divorced from the world we're just
creating these great things there's a
lot of bad stuff going on but but not
here here's where we just create these
amazing products that make everyone's
lives better
everyone here has a more sophisticated
complex view of the world now or at
least I think we do I think we or at
least we need to have one
so that's a really important area for us
and it's an important area affection for
the whole university to be you know
thinking about the potential from
technology but also the complexities of
how do you guide the direction of
Technology what are the second order
effects
uh and so forth so just to pick two
those would be and that's going to talk
about a sort of another broader set of
governance so I'd but I'll let her her
do the talking on that on that one the
by the pick two or three those would
those would be them
uh okay in the front
last couple of years in the way teaching
was done in the way students interacted
in all the aspects of how that happened
and now you've come back
what do you see as the key takeaways
from that in terms of going forward what
did we learn just as you said we're
changing the way we work and rethinking
the last hundred years
is that happening in the education
process and how yeah okay that is a such
a great great question
um so during covet I I led there was a
university group The long-range Recovery
Group and I led that group with a
faculty member from the h s and and that
was our that was the question that was
asked of this group and we had people
from across the University
and we basically came back and said two
two we had two answers to this to this
question
um
one of the answers was there's incr this
is a time of incredible innovation
I mean it really did Force everybody to
think about how to teach how to use
classroom time how to use technology and
it was a revel I mean it's a revelation
what you could do with technology who
knew that on Friday night the Provost
could send an email at Stanford and say
on Monday morning we will be teaching
online
and then on Monday morning
we were teaching online the whole school
was online we did it over a weekend
of course we were terrible at it when we
started I mean truly bet the first day
of coved after we went online
I was giving a guest lecture in one of
the classes
it's a class taught by Peter Wendell and
Eric Schmidt and I was their guest and
we get into the class and I welcome the
class and I said welcome to the GSB
online on zoom and they're waving at me
and I'm like why are they waving at me
and they say the camera is that way
so
it
so we got better over 18 months
so and and so and some of that's coming
back I think into the NBA question
people are using more you know Zoom to
bring speakers in more they did lots of
video people made videos they used that
more flipped classrooms types of stuff
the place we're really using it actually
is in our executive shorter flexible
programs executive programs it's been a
huge um
we had to stop all our executive
programs basically we'd 90 we had a we
have a big Executive Education business
that generates about 80 million a year
in Revenue it turned we had 90 of it was
on campus summer programs it went to
zero during covet
for two summers and instead we tried we
just basically spent 18 months just
trying out new things and some of them
were not successful and some of them
were amazing so like I'll just give you
a couple examples so like one is
we started this type of program in
Executive Education where they're just
these are just like two or three days
short intensive Refreshers on a
particular subject that faculty are Keen
to talk about
turns it's very hard to get people to
come for two days to talk about fintech
or talk about AI or talk about you know
Bitcoin or something whatever the
faculty you're interested in
getting a global audience to spend two
days on Zoom kind of just diving into a
topic of excitement to faculty no
problem so this year we're actually
we're going to work with the engineering
school and we're going to set up a
platform for faculty across Stanford to
offer these Stanford intensives
yeah we could have done that before
coved but we probably would never have
come up with something like we wouldn't
have bothered or just wouldn't have come
to mind and so now you know some things
like that so that's been one great
source of innovation
okay that was the first lesson kind of a
revelation the second Revelation was
what I started with which is
MBA education is just much better in
person
I mean it is just like people were
talking for coved maybe the NBA will be
a hybrid degree people want to zoom in
turns out no our students do not want to
zoom in
like they spent the whole kovid in the
residences
chafing against the covid restrictions
and
when they came off you just see that
that is like it's all about interacting
it's all about the people you meet and
the faculty and engaging in the
classroom and mixing it up and
it's an affirmation of the value of what
happens here on the campus
and part of the lesson of covet is we
just got to get back to doing that get
people back together
oh my gosh okay uh how about the back
you had your hand up for a while
here the flip side of that are the risks
what are the two or three risks that are
biggest in your mind about all this
yeah
um
I mean there's
uh gosh there's always I mean there's
there's always risks uh
you know when I think about sort of the
things that worry me a lot of things
that worry me are just about sort of
into you know people the people on the
campus you're responsible for
for people and and so that's that's you
know during covid that was certainly
something that I worried a lot about and
even now you know I worry about issues
like student mental health and and and
uh issues like you know
the our students and our faculty and and
folks like that it was a they came
through a hard time and it's still
pretty challenging
um institutionally
I I think the I think in some sense it's
Stanford the biggest risks at Stanford
are
are that we become this is gonna I don't
want to say something that's going to
sound bad for our peer schools but
like um
the best thing about Stanford the thing
that brought me here particularly from
here is a faculty member and kept me
here on the faculty for 20 years instead
of going somewhere else is that Stanford
is a relentlessly forward-looking place
Stanford is very unusual in higher
education if you think about higher
education is
how many Industries are there where the
top three organizations in 1705.
are still in the top five today
higher education is like that
and what's amazing about Stanford is you
know 60 years ago 70 years ago Stanford
was a regional University
and it just has had this incredible
Ascent over many many years can partly
in you know because of the people like
you who went through the school and have
gone on and added luster to the
reputation of the institution and
because the faculty and the current
students and all that
and what has driven that is that it's a
very forward-looking entrepreneurial
Innovative not afraid of change place
and so the biggest risk to us is that
somehow we would rest on our Laurels or
we would be complacent or we would start
spending too much time sort of
tried to protect the things we have
instead of
keeping the drive and the
forward-looking and the opportunity
mindset that has made this place so
special remember the recruiting Rush of
the Summer with the shrimp cocktail and
the buffets and especially the second
year recruiting Rush yeah you talked
about how people are rethinking work how
is recruiting changed from what it was
then that is such a great those are the
how does recruiting change that is such
a great question so here's the
interesting thing with the GSB this is
in recruiting this is this is true even
before covet
at basically all of our peer schools
two-thirds of the students get their
jobs through on-campus recruiting and
through their summer internship
we were in a situation before covid
where 10 of our students were taking
their summer internship and turning that
into a job
and
only about a third of our students or
less were getting their jobs through on
campus recruiting
instead we had moved already before
kovid
basically to a world of kind of network
job search
where our students were instead of kind
of waiting for the recruiters to come to
them we're basically looking around
through alumni it was a huge resource
thank you for returning people's calls
uh I'm going to come back that in a
second actually because you're so
important actually in this or they were
looking at LinkedIn or a researching
companies and then going out and
proactively trying to to find places now
some of them still go through recruiting
for consulting firms or private Equity
or what have you but a lot of them were
already in this kind of new world of of
decentralized Network search we had to
go through a huge transition in the way
we support careers in our career
Management Center over the last couple
of years to support that
and covet I think just sort of a little
bit excited that I mean recruiting now
has moved to zoom
uh in large part at least the first
rounds of interviews and so forth
but our students were kind of ahead of
the curve in this as they often are the
last thing I'll just say about this just
just with about the role you all play
you play a big role in our job
placements and I'd say two things about
one is
um uh just to come back to the theme of
gratitude I started with during coven
when we started the pandemic
we had a catastrophe with the student
Job searches because the internships got
canceled and the job market dried up and
when we were in March of 2020 our career
center came to me and to the rest of the
folks in the school leadership and said
we don't have enough jobs just posted at
the career center to get our students
jobs we were about 150 jobs short and
internship short and a time I wrote out
to all of you went to the alumni and I
said we need help
and I'd say that was one of the most
amazing responses that I've ever seen
from an alumni population stamp the GSB
alumni created 300 jobs and internships
in about three weeks
and all of our students got
great opportunities that was incredible
I mean seriously incredible
and you know one of one of our my
colleagues who teaches here has taught
here for a long time and is an Alum of
another school on the East Coast that
sometimes people think of as a pure
School uh
I hope I'm not being recorded no I I am
being recorded uh
but I'll tell the story anyway because
it's a good story so he said
um he was in my opposite and he said you
know
at my alma mater
the alumni book is really thick
it's hugely thick he said every any
industry you look in there's tons of
people
but no one calls you back
is it the GSB looks kind of thin
thinner pretty thick but not as thick
but everyone calls you back
and that's amazing and that's such a
huge asset for our students I just told
our students today because they were
asking about what's going to happen to
the labor market this year
they've got a that's a real Ace in the
Hole for them so you all are the ones
who who make that happen so thank you
for you know everything you do and thank
you for everything you do more generally
for the school it's it's uh we're so
lucky to have this alumni population and
it's so great to get to see you here uh
today and I hope you have a great
weekend
[Applause]
thank you